à partir de demain 70 ans de règne jeudi
vendredi samedi dimanche et pourquoi il
fait et x 70 en 12 ans à [ __ ] de
soixante dix ans à 110 ans est acceptée
moi j'étais à sept ans de règne ici
c'est la france
vous avez une énergie pendant plus de
mille ans et en mille ans de monarchie
vous avez eu à celle jubilé de platine
l'an xiv en huile et nord byron jubilé
de panique c'est yann savel donc s'ils
cèdent pas proportionnel l'angleterre
n'a jamais de jubiler plaît sinon bah
ouais mais c'est quand même bien deux
ans elle bat louis xiv ne jure sur ma
vie ça va le roi soleil ouais bon et
vous tenir dedans alors est ce qu'elle
est à la
taille totale est pas top top mais les
fans elle les fera là
[Rires]
que j'aimerais connaître ce santé à
l'antenne la reine elizabeth et elle
sera là voilà merci alors la défense
maintenant que la réponse la reine
la reine elizabeth est un tout petit peu
ferrals
la reine elizabeth souffre de crises
d'art trop élevés dans le temps et
menacent l annonce même un peu des
orages ou devait annoncer que le cadrage
ou sur l'arthrose le mans que demain
pour la première manifestation qui va
être shopping vous savez cette grande
parade militaire où tous les régiments
de l'infanterie vont défiler et qui va
durer plus de deux ore no 1400
militaires 240 chevaux 400 musiciens ne
sera probablement pas la meilleure c'est
son jubilé c'est comme si moi j'ai pas
mon adversaire à la fin donc grande vous
allez voir tous les windsor vont arriver
en lance à mousse etc qu'à laisser ces
gens qui écrivent ce qu'ils aient wilson
la famille des sapeurs oui ça son fils
sacha
[Rires]
un
[Applaudissements]
trou et médiane qui devrait arriver sur
le sol anglais dans quelques minutes jet
privé tous les aimons tous alors
finalement quel point tu parles de ça tu
es tout agitée mais mais ça fait des
années que j'attends ce népotisme
et la mégane et la rio est en effet donc
il va y avoir tout le monde à fossa il
arrête à l'arrivée la faim en arc rose
est la reine
de ce défilé qui va durer deux heures
sur whitehall l'ensemble de la famille
royale va rentrer au palais dans les
landes au unnim sanogo
eux seront à cheval non et lorsque il
faut déjà franchir les cris de
buckingham et porte la reine va
apparaître au balcon mais elle serait
probablement balfour comment laurent
tenues ouvre même en tenue de ouf non
c'est déjà la rentrée mais tout bas oui
pour le coup les bookmakers sont partis
de paris non j'aurais pas cavaler chez
kuoni
les combats dans l'est du joueur mais
ford a morlaix d'une robe jérémy karlund
comparer sur la couleur de la robe a
parlé d'une robe de chez rim it alone
abacha mais je n'ai pas
[Rires]
mme
[Applaudissements]
edan valentino hier sa valentino rossi
et avec le magal tankian leurs machines
mcqueen a légué mais tous pensent à eux
deux marques préférées moi je rappelle
avec helsinn sort au moment où la reine
apparaît au balcon 70 avions de la royal
oak être que sont prêtes pas dans la
tronche en vont servir aux étangs qui
met le drapeau de l'union jack ils ont
déjà servi
il a
aimé savions exactement quand ils
arrivent ils 70 ans ont survolé le
palais de beys en faisant quoi
rapidement les couleurs mais avec quoi
ils ont appris mon
garçon dollars il le fait avec son hub
apprennent des drapeaux
je suis pro c'est pas
genre que 124 coup de canon vous êtes
retiré de la demande et 42,2 ait pour
toi là c'est très technique pour le coup
ça correspond au nombre de bataillons de
régiment je veux bien mais deux c'est
quoi c'est la voiture de rennes
on va dire ça un beau pied ça à la nuit
tombante un arbre gigantesque de 42
mètres de long va s'embraser tout entier
non et va donner le signal tout le
commonwealth twain meilleur nord de
grand feu de joie et ça va être à une
saveur locale 7 vols quelle que soit la
cause d'envolée un arbre tous les pays
du commonwealth et qui c'est qui qui se
commande à un arbre sculpture
romane tous ces pays sur laquelle la
reine et chefs d'état le commandant
moussa le canada n'a pas chômé
bah oui bateau au canada c'est sur le
billet sur les dollars c'est la
lp2
sujet à travers le monde a les rênes de
ce maroc et l'ue ça faisait longtemps
que j'avais pas vu je fais wesh tu date
du coi
cookies et qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
alors elle dit moi aussi alors ça c'est
le premier jour il ya assez de place et
le jeudi à 9 heures les quatre joueurs
là on est là jusqu'à
la journée un peu plus solennel c'est
saint paul et qui a été retenu ça pulse
est affamé et nice du mariage de charles
et de camilla et de charme et de diana
le toit
n'a pas retenu à l'abbaye de wesminster
mclaren toi tu as le temps il est 20h40
il est vrai c'est la poire et dire que
qui va officier et lines et tout le
gratin politique qui va prendre place
votre vie ministres ambassadeurs consuls
et son entier qui va être là voilà qui
arrive emmanuel mac ou non non non non
uniquement les représentants des pays du
commonwealth pour le coup des chefs
d'état pour le coup d'un benoît haaby
oui absolument le fils étudie sa
quarante cinq minutes ils savent et
valeur dit un jour où il faut faire un
disque au genre elle n'a rien du tout
alors la famille royale va arriver en
grande pompe à
[Rires]
tous avec des grandes banques voilà des
très belles voitures si vous le vendredi
ça va être les bijoux automobile
derrière eux des barres
de combien sera utilisable et 2g poche
le garagiste 9 non ça
comme ça deux fantômes 6 on va enfin
pouvoir voilà ça qu'on les voie normale
5 rolls jeu lors des mariages lotois
calme-toi tout
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
pas pénétré par une petite porte dérobée
du tout par la grande porte pourquoi
parce que vous savez vous savez la
cathédrale saint-paul ya des marches
interminables
va lui éviter cela donc c'est à dire sur
[Musique]
le lien
nous voici france à ce que tu dis
rien
non mais je te le dis est ce que tu veux
dire alors
à la fin à la disposition de skoda elle
va arriver là n'auraient alors à l'issue
de la série a à l'issue de la messe
on aimait samedi le samedi c'est le
derby d'epsom c'est le chantier
londonien on
pense bien qu'elle n'y sera pas parce
que elle avait trois chevaux favoris et
les trois chevaux se sont blessés
elle ne devra pas y assister et par
contre lorsque meghan markle a décidé de
faire d'organiser un anniversaire
surprise de libye bête
souvenez vous sachiez devient jamais
remplacé cédric un même cri non c'est la
fille de mégane et ça coûte combien
cette connerie dire à budget de 9
millions d'euros a été alloué quatre
jours oui et ça va rapporter combien ça
coûte moi je crois que c'est plus value
mais oui bien sûr que ça va coûter plus
mieux
construites harkis ont été mis à
contribution des sponsors donc en vain
combat ça coûtait 100 lgts avec tout le
monde quand ils ont mis combien d'autres
que 60 des avions neufs mais c'est un
internement 2,9 millions
exposer sa tribune la banque barclays
par exemple qui sponsorise le concert
ici le ch à doha une de jeu vous
connaissez bien jacques brie et dee
spencer 4 0 et
jure sur ma vie sur cadbury bien sûr il
y aura des finger et bien il y aura des
distributions de beaucoup de chance
maubourguet ce que je voulais c'est que
médiane en a quand même profité pour
ramener un tout petit peu la couverture
à elle elle organise l'anniversaire donc
de huit bêtes ah mais ça aura lieu donc
le samedi jour des hommes tu va rater
tout ça
on a rationné la reine et regarder les
sondages du soir la reine et helle
ferrals oui à
50% du revenu pense que la reine n'est
pas faire ils ont tenté de l'économie
c'est vous savez il ya quelque chose
très drôle le comité d'organisation de
ce jubilé à rêver n'est que le chef qui
est hugo vickers il a reçu comme le
meurtre du palais de lui dire non
n'oubliez pas les gens et surtout ne
tuez pas l'arrêt ces normes
[Rires]
c'est à marmande et lui robert quand
racontera d'autres conneries
absolument on a gagné oui elle s'appelle
gma est alors 700 une note
j'ai mal à la tête
6 2
[Applaudissements]
on attend 1,6 million de personnes
à fons j'en ai rien à battre
l'échouement droit les coûts
écrit la capitale du mali
[Applaudissements]
attendez
impacté raison
les gars tu auras pas que c'est les
anglais de sale
je plaisante
[Musique]
avec ottawa
aller à ma maman si lara n'est pas
non non j'ai du temps moi ça va
[Applaudissements]
les gens qui m'ont
franchement
non mais y'a des mecs qui m'arrive oui
vraiment
pas se mettre là l'astuce oui tout
matelas non sa vache
janish sommet je m'en vais tanner jolis
cheveux sinon ça qu'on est là je te dis
je m'en bats les couilles
une vidéo tu fais là
tu peux rester un pays non lorsque jean
[ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]